bill and Eileen alley spoke to us about
the addiction that nearly killed their
son David the heroin started getting the
better of him
I kept calling the police on him hoping
the police would arrest him I spent many
days following him wondering where he's
at texting my husband go check on David
go make sure he's breathing checking on
him like he was a newborn child we take
turns getting up in the middle of night
make sure our son was still alive I
heard I heard those signs of you know
heroin the dance the slap the bouncing I
call it his heroin dance and I went down
and I said David I can't take it no more
I don't want to do it no more I
physically I'm not able to well he was
so high he cussed me out
he called me some names that he's never
ever called me and I knew at that moment
that I had to do something and I went up
and told his dad what had happened and I
went to my mom's for the night and I let
him handle it he said what do you want
nothing was going on and I pointed at
the door I said see that door I said get
out it I said don't come back until you
are off of that crap and he left
and the last time I seen him before he
overdosed again he was walking down the
driveway and he turned around and looked
at me and just smirked and said take a
good look it's the last time you're
gonna see me alive and he went and
stayed with some people that cared about
him he was there for not even two weeks
and he overdosed again they had they had
to kick their bathroom door in and do
CPR on him until the ambulance got there
they tell us EMS workers here in
Middletown Ohio saved their son's life
four times
he's now in rehab in Columbus and we're
told he's doing well we asked them about
a city councilman suggestion that EMS
may have to stop responding to calls
when patients overdose three times or
more even though they're down there
they're high on heroin they still
deserve to live they just don't know it
they're consumed by an addiction you
know there's people out there that don't
have any sympathy for people with
addictions and you know they believe the
narcan should be cut off after three
times all I can say is I hope they never
have to change their stance on it
because if they do that means some
things were something really bad has
happened to someone they love I do get
it I really do some of these stories are
very heart wrenching and I feel very
sorry for everybody or anybody who has
this issue but people need to understand
that I'm a city councilor my job as the
city councilor is to make sure this city
can continue to function and provide
services to its citizens and at the rate
we're going we've got to do something I
think I think we should save every life
we possibly can but what do we do when
we don't any money it angers me that's a
death sentence to thousands of people
thousands of people that's not the
answer to the drug problem there's not
the answer to our heroin epidemic
our town is in crisis full-blown crisis
we need help and taking away the narcan
it's not gonna help it's gonna make it
worse
the bodies are gonna add up the families
are gonna mourn these people need a
chance like my son head for CBS this
morning Tony to copal Middletown Ohio